it's just a tough time defending i'm
sorry
so we got to clean up that's enough
i don't know i look at the film figure
it out
it was like a blur tonight i'm saying
yeah
i'm good
there was more on chris paul's mind than
the game afterwards i want to find
players for saying stuff to the fans but
the fans can put their hands on our
families
uh and then dave mcmenamin
says a source familiar with chris paul's
tweet after game four told espn that
paul's mother had hands put on her by
dallas fans and paul's wife was also
pushed to make matters worse paul's kids
witnessed it they felt very unsafe
the source said
natalie the force
for the dallas mavericks the mavs are
aware of an incident between a fan and
the family of chris paul it was
unacceptable behavior will not be
tolerated
the mavs along with american airlines
center swiftly through the fan from
today's game
shaq you want to weigh in
you know a way to prevent that is listen
we're all from the same place we all
have cousins when you come into a
hostile arena one of your cousins ain't
doing nothing you got one job to do
watch my wife watch my kids and watch my
mama and if anybody get out of line you
have my permission to touch them up
point-blank period you know like you
know fans don't know how to act
sometimes you know things like this
happen we can't expect our wives and our
mothers to you know be there to enjoy
the game and you know people bullying
them and all that stuff so
poop dog and mookie they was always with
a miss lucille and she ain't never had
no problem because they had my
permission say something to my mom you
get touched up
yeah i mean listen
the fans are great the fans are great
but there's always going to be one or
two or five that's going to get look it
up i won't insult people
i i don't
uh insulting is one thing putting hands
on somebody's uh well we don't know the
extent uh who put hands on who to be
honest with you uh they could have put
hands on them first too you just we
don't know the extent of that i don't
like accusing people going by crap we
see on the internet
but
you're not supposed to put your hands on
anybody uh but
i don't know what happened but when you
go in a hostile environment there's
always going to be some look it up fans
i've always said
hey we could put into all this stuff
some of this stuff these fans say
let's take them right down to center
court for five minutes
i've always said that some of the crap
they said to you hey let's give me five
minutes to send a court with him and to
say
you ain't gonna press no charges
nobody gonna get it no and no ain't
nobody gonna be sued civilly say what
you just said to me right to my face
right here for these five minutes and
i'm gonna beat your ass beat the hell
out of it it would take you five minutes
oh no i'm gonna take my time
i'm not gonna beat them up quickly
i'm gonna jab them a little bit then i'm
gonna lay the haymakers on their ass
well obviously i hear you foreign
charles foreman in the real world in a
real society
you know other than the gladiator that
no we purging people it's not happening
we're purging people i i mean i think
your earlier point was 100 right
you know how uh you always wonder how
those mob things start if something
happened everybody join in so
anytime you bring your family or anybody
on the road
you need to talk to security first of
all
the team should send security with you
anyway we talked about that you you
never take your family
and kids i'm like i'm like shaq said i'm
taking my my bodyguard with me
or i don't have a grown man there to
protect them because ernest some of this
stuff like listen when i played for the
76ers some of the stuff they would shout
at our own team
was brute i played with a guy who got
two quick fouls every game and we asked
him why they do that he says because i
can't stand what they're saying to me in
the stands they don't talk to me when
i'm on the bench
i mean and we're like we like what do
you what did you just say he said man i
just can't handle the pressure they're
screaming they're talking about my mom
and my kids and everything but when i
get them two quick fouls and go to the
bench they leave me alone so sorry not
that you'd name names but who was it
child sacrifice
so